all right so everyone seems to be
talking about how long one piece has
been going on for and you know what it
has it has been going on for a super
long time but there is another manga
that actually dwarfs even one piece
Conan has been running continuously for
almost 30 years yeah that's right
Detective Conan has been running for so
long that when it started DVDs hadn't
even been released yet in fact DVDs had
been invented released and usurped by
Blu-ray all within the lifespan of
Detective Conan Playboy magazine was
still illegal in Ireland people were
still using Windows NT I don't even know
what that is the city of Mumbai was
still named Bombay Major League Soccer
hadn't even begun existing in the US yet
NAFTA didn't exist yet and oh yeah
that's right by the time one piece
decided to start Detective Conan was
already a hundred chapters deep into its
run